two parents convicted of child abuse get
probation
instead of prison time the i-team's
vanessa murphy is taking a closer look
at the case
now we do want to warn you the images in
this report are disturbing
and show the child's injury
these are photos of a seven-year-old
with injuries bruises and scars
all over his body metro police say his
parents ashley adams and david england
whipped him with a cord and a belt and
that the child said adams once threw a
boot at his head
he was hospitalized with serious
injuries
this is how
child abuse it is one of the worst
whipping cases
i have ever done in my career
on may 19th clark county chief deputy
district attorney dina renetti argued
for 12 years in prison for the parents
the maximum sentence specified in a plea
deal despite no criminal history
there are some cases not often but there
are some cases
that deserve prison despite a lack of a
criminal record
and this is one of them adams in england
pleaded guilty to three felony counts of
child abuse after they were
initially charged with 19 counts this is
ongoing torture of this
child your honor this
is the face of child abuse
this is a face of a child
in crisis court records reveal the
parents admitted to beating the child
and adams said her son would cry and
scream
two years later in clark county district
court england said he was the victim of
abuse as a child
and both parents told judge beta yeager
they're sorry and have taken steps like
counseling to change
i'm not a bad person at all i love my
kids to death
and i just wanted to be a mom
to them again and show them how much i
miss them how much
i have changed and learned along the
course of these two years ja jager
handed the parents suspended sentences
of 72 to 180 months
they will both spend less than 60 days
in the county jail
be on probation for five years and if
they stay out of trouble
they'll spend no time in state prison it
was revealed in court they are trying to
be
reunited with the boy and his little
sister who are currently in foster care
renee says these images are warning
signs
something even worse could have happened
to the child who will now live with
lifelong trauma caused by his own
parents
we need justice for this child vanessa
murphy 8 news now
now by law in nevada parents are allowed
to discipline their children by spanking
them as long as it does not cause an
injury to the child if you're aware of
possible child abuse or neglect
you're urged to report it in clark
county you can call 702-399-0081